all right today's topic let's check it
out hey guys it's Kristin I'm Bethany
your hair with girl to find ministries
hey just the way you say hey guys I get
the feeling I'm pretty almost 100%
certain you work at Macy's
hey guys welcome to Macy's oh it's
Kristin and Bethany you're here with
girl to find ministries and in today's
vlog we really want to talk about the
modern woman struggle with sexual sin so
this posture Chris and I both really had
a burden just to help young women in
women who are struggling with sexual sin
we've received email after email from
girls who are saying I've never told
anyone about this and I'm struggling
with this talk about masturbation don't
struggle freak you're being to bring
give a what 230 leave this up formatted
with your finger flick the bean Quran
let's go
flick your bean flick it if you want to
flick someone else's being or you're
down there just look at it and be like
hey open up the conversation you may
have heard of radical parody which we
hosted this past summer to kind of open
up the conversation and radical pure
radical purity is this like radical
Islam except instead of instead of
blowing yourselves up you go around
telling people not to blow up there are
you you don't tell people they can't
have explosions where it matters is that
what it is this is a radical purity keep
that explosion in your pants from an
exploding sure you know young women and
women are struggling with secret sins
and we need to talk about it we need to
talk about what's really going on and
through that conference I think both of
our eyes were just opened even more to
how real this struggle is and I think
for the first time because we were
talking about it girls came up to us and
yeah I mean even women saying hey I
don't like this this is a problem
calling it a sin getting people to not
[ __ ] sport this is the from that's
you know what it is
this creates pedophile I mean this
happens in the south of the states in
the Jemez me me me me me over there I
was researching I know people from the
South estates and when they talk to me
about religion almost like well you
really think that way cuz in Canada
honestly it's not this or aggressive the
problem with this kind of sexual
Presonus in this kind of language is it
guilty people for sex and it also
stigmatizes people that are dealing with
it so people who are gay are now having
to live in the shadows as a result of
these kinds of the rhetoric and where
it's born from so you know sex workers
who otherwise in other countries we're
able to work out in the open are now
hovering to relegate themselves to the
underworld and that's dangerous it puts
them in a place where they can't turn to
the police if crimes happen so all
honestly while we Jack Bobby Jack off
because I'm sexual sin you know well
we're just around I mean will we jack
off for out [ __ ] when we will we jerk
[ __ ] again when we joke about these
things yes it's fine but honestly it is
a big problem and it has that to where
society is today where a woman showing
your lip on television is the end of the
[ __ ] world because we live Instagram
exactly we live in such a puritanical
society that we still see these things
as negative and I can't wait for us to
move past this so that people today are
making YouTube videos like this where
they're trying to push this back into
the past they have the right to do it I
just think these ideas are unhealthy and
I don't [ __ ] with what they're saying if
you think about it the boob is not
sexual I get my milk from there
free the nipple free to nipple since
this is the topic he's coming into the
light I feel like I can finally share
and I feel like maybe I can finally have
some freedom from this nobody could
understand nobody to talk about it
because people like this referred to it
as sexual sin the reason why nobody and
could talk to you and you couldn't find
information about this online then
because it's considered a sin right and
that's the big problem so actually it's
very sad that women who are struggling
with this are finding these people as a
people to confine him because now
they're just gonna reinforce that guilt
and tell them that the urges and I think
that they're feeling but they shouldn't
act on them that they shouldn't ever
indulge and I'm not saying go out there
and [ __ ] everything there's a fine line
between sexual liberation and just
cheapening yourself out there but that's
for everyone for this there's a fire for
themselves but but what I will say is
that this kind of repressive news has
really dominated on North American and
Western society and it's been terrible
for us it has been terrible and we have
not learned in points of consent we have
not learned the importance of good sex
and caring for your partner how to
receive pleasure and give it these are
very important aspects of a good sex
life and sexual repression like this
stops us from getting there
even if you want to talk about like your
thinking's you oh yeah I got able to
talk about it
yeah okay but you still refer as sin so
even if you talk about it you still talk
about something that is wrong shameful
shameful and wrong-foot swak even if you
think yeah I'm open to talk about it
yeah I need freedom from the very thing
that your rhetoric has imprisoned me in
I'll tell you what this is like this is
like people imprisoning you right and
then you start talking to your jailor
about freedom and your jailer who has
the keys just looking at you like yeah I
know it sucks to be in prison and you're
like finally have someone I can talk to
me okay
loves Donnie the reason we're scared to
speak up it's because we're believing
some lies so girls may think something
like my family and friends would be
shocked if they knew what I struggled
with and that lie can really keep us in
bondage because we think oh they think
I'm this perfect Christian girl if I
speak up what's gonna happen to my
reputation the reason why they can't
talk is because they're afraid of the
Christian shame which is what we said
sexual repression comes from your
religion good job parents gonna think
but forgetting is only found when we
speak up and I are actually honest about
our sins that's when we can find help
everybody have used me as the good
Christian girl so I can't tell them how
can you save speak up and call it sin
you literally call it a [ __ ] problem
you're saying that what people are
feeling and their ability to tackle with
it is negative you tell women to aspire
to be the good Christian girl that is
what you encourage and of course when
they don't live up to that they're going
to feel shame you are shaming them and
then telling them let's talk about the
fact you feel shame how about you just
don't shame them do not talk about the
topic I'm still waiting for them to talk
about the topic this should not talk
about the topic top to cut them soppy
know it can be so hard because this is
extremely personal you don't know what a
response might be
but the Bible isn't silent on this topic
two verses that have been specifically
helpful for us in thinking about it for
ourselves and in helping others has been
James 5:16 in Galatians 5:1 James 5:16
says therefore can
that's your sins to one another and pray
for one another that you may be healed
we went from sin to problem and now
ladies and gentlemen it's a disease
we're going another verse that I love
collations 5-1 for freedom Christ has
set us free stand firm therefore and do
not submit again to yoga sleep I love
that one racism yeah how about we mix it
in with this whole foods battered bread
mmm give me some of that mayonnaise I
love vanilla mmm
you have any good old-fashioned racism
no like the one where we put them down
Oh Reid's bad you don't have that okay
well you know what instead of racism and
slavery can we have the yoke of slavery
I like the yoke yeah I love it yeah in
order to complete this recipe we need a
good old-fashioned Hey valley girl head
till three - yeah we went from sin to
problem to disease and now it's slavery
we're going down baby
no no no no no it's yoke of slavery the
slave habit we are Christians believers
in Jesus Christ we have that strength
within us and his strength truly is made
perfect and our weakness he didn't come
so that we could continue to be slaves
to our slin slaves to this bondage
that's what Satan wants for us he wants
us to steal kill and destroy to keep us
in our sin but Christ wants us to be
free so remember that but how Christ you
love me Christ wants us to be free and
who preaches this word the pastors and
what did the pastor's do they're free
when they [ __ ] little boys that's not
basses that do that but whatever no
who's it it's priests pastors the D [ __ ]
everything by the pastor who was lady
came in to church one day and during
services she said it's pastor what do I
do about my sexual urges can you help me
and the pastor says come see me for a
nighttime service it'll be just meeting
you
I really just recommend to talk to
someone talk to someone you trust share
with them what's going on and then I
hope that through their counsel through
their advice and just through the
strength of the Holy Spirit you can
start to walk in freedom in this area or
you could just masturbate so if you're
sitting there right now and you're
thinking wow I have some sexual sense
and secrets and that I've never told
anyone and this is eating away at me we
hope you found today's video helpful no
no [ __ ] I hope you find this helpful
best of the way what did you say nothing
you beat around the bush well you should
have beat around the bush in fact the
booze push push in the bush panic panic
I mean I'll let women kind of talk about
this as much as they want because I
think I mean this kind of rhetoric
affects men as well but we're giving
much more leeway to be out there and be
sinful than ladies are so I think it's a
little unfortunate I swear but I do find
this kind of rhetoric dangerous because
again it contributes to sexual
repression sexual repression and shame
makes it dangerous for sex workers and
makes it a everybody for gay people and
makes it dangerous for people who are
having six outside of marriage on all
that changing that stigma results in
people having less pleasure in sex less
safety in sex and overall a worse time
so I may not endorse this I do not like
this I think a world in which we talk
openly and freely about sex is a
positive one provided we're being
responsible and what these people are
preaching is you forgot to mention what
disease people are not informed about
disease about getting pregnant and not
pregnant about all that all the
precedent that you can talk about it you
can get proper information yeah that's a
big problem with it is that people don't
get don't talk about that but if you
they're repressed so therefore they do
things aren't that [ __ ] they do things
all castorini be on the back of people
about child you know but they don't know
about nothing about how to get protected
how to not [ __ ] not happen and even
worse though is that all this
conditioning makes it so that you see
the sinful and shameful so for someone
who's trying to enjoy the sexual
experience their whole life they've been
told that this is negative that this is
bad how do they find a way to get out of
their own head and just enjoy the
physical experience if their
conditioning is so deep if you refer to
it as a disease which I associate with
negative things that's the yoke of
slavery then how am I supposed to have
sex for the first time and be like
I'm open to this experience your slavery
problem since yo you know Alan
so you [ __ ] why this is why
it's so and care you have to be so
careful about what terms you use when
you associate things with it because I
have after a while that action becomes
associated with those words right when
you say toxic masculinity what do people
think you're saying masculine is toxic
when you say sex is a sexual sin what do
they think that anything sexual related
is sinful and therefore bad when you say
something like the yoke of slavery well
then goddamn that is one of the worst
period in history and that's what you're
gonna use to refer to my urges of course
I'm not gonna have a positive opinion of
sex you know what's funny is they called
it the yoke of slavery and I find it
fascinating
why because every time I beat my black
penis I please blacks until the light
comes up yeah the yoke of slavery the
root of it it's pretty good right have
that for breakfast
[Music]